[Music]
hello
my name is cecil slipovic and i'm
musician in residence at yale
university's
fortune of video archive for holocaust
testimonies
this video series is designed as a
companion to our album
where is our homeland which is the first
volume in the archives ongoing effort
to present songs and poems performed by
survivors in testimonies given to the
fortune of archive
over the last 40 years you can learn
more about the project on the archives
website
songsfromtestimonies.org
where is our homeland songs from
testimonies volume 1
was recorded in 2019 by the cecil
slepovich ensemble
featuring renowned singer sasha luria
craig udelman on the violin joshua camp
on the accordion
keyboards and guitar dmitry ishenko on
the base
and myself on woodwinds the songs in
this collection differ vastly in terms
of style
social and historical background
language and many other aspects
but collectively they create a
multi-dimensional picture
of jewish life before and during world
war
ii parrot's age was born in 1927
in warsaw he was a child when the war
broke out
he used to sing in the streets of warsaw
to earn a living and he shared several
songs
in his 1993 fortune of video archive
testimony
one of them is vales francois waltz
francois
composed in 1905 by adam yusef
karashinsky to the lyrics of ange
waste that song was a salon waltz
that enjoyed enormous popularity in
poland
in the first half of the 20th century
there is no surprise
that a song written in what originally
was a sentimentalism era
salon genre with the lyrics expressing
the longing
for the golden times golden era
of the past gained such enormous
popularity
vals francois ended up among many songs
that parrots h was singing for his
livelihood during the warning
[Music]
[Music]
from
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
she
[Applause]
[Music]
from
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
francois belongs to this repertoire
of street musicians singers
who wanted to survive during german
occupation
in warsaw using
heats from pre-war time
to make their living to survive
and in many cases these heats
came from abroad to poland that was a
case of
chiletalindo but this is not the case
of arts francois it originated from
this very unique milieu of
pre-war polish jewish
artistic circles on
the turn of 19 20 centuries
and there are some special characters
of this story which i would like to
say a few words about the first is
adam karashinsky a polish musician and
composer
who is an author of false francois
it was a year 1905
reception devoted to his
colleague composer and friend and
on that very party he for the first time
performs this melody
of vance francois which
quickly gained popularity and
became one of the main polish
vars melodies and karashinski was called
the king of polish violence at that time
he died in 1920
he so there's we had a family polish
jewish family his wife was jewish
and their son zbigniew kalashninsky
became a new editor
now author of new version of this song
in 1920
as bigness is a very very
interesting personality he became one of
the
pioneers of polish dress
and before the war during the war and
after the war
time he was very engaged in developing
orchestras compositions concerts devoted
to
mostly jazz music also popular music but
when the year 1968 came
his anti-semitic action by the
communist regime in poland he emigrated
abroad so this is when
one part of that story from
karashi karashinski's family
another character very important maybe
the crucial one for the popularity of
our song
is andrey wass
a polish jew coming from
wooch who came towards so
at that time and became
one of the major figures of developing
so-called polish mass culture
with israelis cabarets and so on many
people
consider him the first
person who who was confident
about the need of mass culture
in a new post war post first world war
in poland at that time
so firstly he started to cooperate with
the most famous and i think the best
cover we had in pre-war time in poland
cui broke four with such names
as julian twohim and hammer
comparing to anju who asked as they were
more ambitious
the poetry the lyrics
was on the higher level but andre was
like to compose and
to produce more
popular repertoire lesson issues
that's why he was called cruel
smear in pre-world war so the king
of sheba which is a less ambitious
repertoire
softly saying but
there were of course the peers of poetry
in his lyrics as well
he was an author of such songs as
rebecca
very popular also after the war
especially whenever the marching started
to perform it
and he he was the author of uh
of the lyrics to waltz francois
and it became a heat of a
new cabaret he established in 1927
in warsaw which was called
morsky occult ci
new which was called
[Music]
warsaw's casino de paris
because it was influenced very
heavily by the french
tradition of radia and cabaret
especially casino de paris also moulin
rouge
and others he was traveling very often
to paris at that time and
taking the models you know the the
inspiration from that tradition
and it was very much about these
culture in war so it was very much
french oriented
and that was also the reason that warsaw
was called at that time the paris of the
knowles
and andre was was very responsible for
for that title and we we may understand
why it was called vaals francois
the french culture was very attractive
and at the background of this
music
he was author of such hits
as a lyrics
writer as tango milanka i
think the the most popular
composition at that time coming from
poland
composed by years petersburski
and with international fame
among the singers performing this
composition was edit piaf
and uh it was also performed on broadway
in uh johnson
musicals so very successful
[Music]
heat coming also from that milieu
in warsaw the
it is
worthwhile to mention also a very tragic
fate of anjiv was during
holocaust he he was
close in warsaw ghetto and
there are different variants of
his deaths one of them is saying that
his friends make the whole action
to take him out from warsaw ghetto but
when he saw german soldiers he went to
panic and was shut down
at the spot
we don't know exactly how how it was
but he he perished
in in that time in warsaw
what about
[Music]
the laters
history of our song
it is still popular in
poland you may find it in
such productions as
the tv series
a godliness borja botswana very popular
in poland in the 90s
or recent of last century
but mainly
the living of of this song and
composition
is because
it's popul its popularity is because
uh the performance by taloush can turn
the death
class from 1975.
and there is an anecdote behind it why
cantor
use this melody in his performance
it was his wife maria stangert
who was humming during
the
presence in one of the krakow's cafe
uh having this melody and cantor
immediately said
oh this is the melody for our
performance
why i think that it was
the the whole performance which is one
of the most important
performance of 20th century not only
polish theater
the reason for that i think is that the
whole performance
is about coming back to our childhood
time to our school time
to revoke the memories also traumatic
memories from that
very time and this melody serves
on that there in in that
in in this case very
strongly so when we think today
about uh vals francois it's very much
about coming back to our
childhood to our past
with the nostalgia with this kind of
feeling
we we still have
of returning to better
times uh to the golden age
something like that and precisely
that was the reason country use
for this very dramatic performance and
and there is no other music in the
performance only it's like a
light motif from the beginning to the
end repeat it and repeat it in the
performance
and almost conducted by cantor who was
present on the stage and
and and conducting this
this music so we still
keep it in our minds in our hearts
in our culture and
we should remember mostly i think the
last
verses of the song
if only it would evoke in these hearts
of evil
the magic of that french vaults
i think we should still do our best
to keep it to keep this magic to counter
the evil
in our hearts
[Music]
you
[Music]